well this is much anticipated so i
wonder
first of all for you how did you first
get involved in this series and
you know what's the reaction when you
hear you're going to be working with
prince harry and oprah and directing
friends
all over the world people are in some
kind of
mental psychological emotional pain
what words have you heard around mental
health crazy
lost it can't keep it together this has
been a labor of love for the last two
years
obviously the pandemic threw us quite a
curveball
i first got a call from a production
company that i had worked with before
i'd done a four part series through
netflix and they said
oprah is interested in talking to you
and i was like oprah
winfrey like there's another airport i
was gonna say how many other openers do
you know don
it's actually a funny story um i was in
new york and they're
you know we were gonna talk by phone and
they said she's to be in new york why
don't you come meet her so i said great
um it was a may day in new york and if
you know the weather there can be really
change it had been warm at the beginning
of the week
it got really cold at the end of the
week so i only had one dress
i put it on in the hotel in the dark and
i could get into a taxi and a bottle of
lotion
had opened up all over my dress that i
was on the taxi
to go meet oprah with so i kind of met
her like this
and i like leaned in you know and i
think she thought i was like really
like emotional so she leaned in
so i think my spotty dress like maybe
did something
um but in all seriousness um
she was really looking for some
immersive storytelling
um she and harry had been prince harry
had been speaking about this for a long
time it was really important for them
and they you know they were so involved
every step of the way we had bi-weekly
meetings
uh on the zoom my kids thought it was
hilarious that i was zooming with prince
harry and oprah
um but that is kind of hilarious that's
it's kind of iconic don i hope you took
one screenshot of that
you know what i did um uh
you know we we kind of all persevered
and i think the importance of what we
were doing
um really pushed us all to do our best
and to make it work however we could
also to honor our subjects i mean we
have the most incredible lineup of
people
both well-known and not well-known each
of them said to us
they want to help somebody and they're
telling their stories and opening up
like they haven't before and that by the
way includes
prince harry and includes oprah it took
a little convincing but um
she opened up uh as well and and you
know i can now say
i got to interview the queen i got to
interview oprah winfrey so that was also
a huge
um experience for me i know how that
feels it's a it's like a
wild out of body experience moment
out of body is exactly right like
sometimes i was like
we're talking to oprah let's talk about
the name of this the me
you can't see i mean that's so very
powerful
um where did it come from and and kind
of how was that settled on
so the name actually came from oprah and
prince harry um
they kind of we all were like banding
around different names
and that just kind of sees the
imagination of
everyone because so many mental health
issues
there's so much stigma around the idea
that you have a mental health condition
that people hide it and so you might see
you know people who look glamorous and
beautiful and look like they have
everything
you know everything is right in their
world and actually there's just turmoil
happening
inside or at home with family members or
people that they love
so we thought it was really important to
say this is not only what's invisible
but it's also a part of you
like whatever mental health struggles
you're happy you're having
those are a part of you also so how do
you embrace those
and live with them not live in spite of
them
yeah i i think it's interesting you were
saying you know um
having um oprah and and harry sit down
took some convincing and really kind of
go there with each other
to make that decision to receive help
is not a sign of weakness in today's
world more than ever
it is a sign of strength what kind of
safe space was created because we know
oprah's the queen of creating a safe
space so what kind of safe space was
created
for them and with them to be able to do
that
yeah each of them so asif kapedia is the
other director he's based in london
so he worked really closely with prince
harry and then um
i worked really closely with with uh ow
um and so you know i had a number of
conversations with her
and she kept saying it's not about me
it's not about me
um but i think it became clear as we saw
the subjects that were opening up
that she also had a story to tell so she
had a story both as a caregiver but her
own personal story
and those were the hardest i mean to
tell you the truth we were
we did create a safe space we did it um
in a private house
on uh her you know her home
compound we had a very small crew
it was really just the two of us having
a conversation
so you know i was doing my best oprah
like to give her
space to access memory and to tell us
about things that are hard you know
she's so used to being on one side of
the chair
it was really communicating to her that
i was listening
um that she was i knew she was going to
tell me things that were hard
um but just encouraging her to to
continue to do what she's done for so
long
which is to help people through her
vulnerability and through her curiosity
so um it was we we both cried
quite a few times as you can imagine um
but
you know she gave me the best compliment
i could ever um
you know have in saying that that she
enjoyed the interview and she felt it
was cathartic for her
i can't imagine that it was easy i'm
sure it was very
that harry was very nervous um to talk
about
self-medicating with drugs and with
alcohol
that like he did um
was did was he nervous to go to that
place
um i think anytime anyone
reveals something personal and painful
that
there's anxiety about that um
and so i think it's a real credit to
ossif to our director
that he established a relationship where
prince harry felt really comfortable and
felt like
i also think he had discussed it he
thought about it he knew what he was
signing up for um and he also knew
the thing that's so important about the
series is that it be authentic that
that'd be real
and i think um he was willing to do that
for that reason
i think also you know as he discloses
he's been through a lot of therapy
he understands the power of talking of
it's very important to him that things
be accurate and real
and present and i think that this this
experience was part of that
do we know if he's sober now or if he
you know
because he had been through a lot of
therapy he talked about those things and
realizing that self-medicating was not
the way to heal
um do we know um as far as i know he's
completely sober he's in such a great
place
in his life in his mental wellness and
in his health
and you know he works hard at that and
he
the most important thing to him uh you
know from what we can tell is being a
husband and a father
but also to giving back that is so
amazing and you know one of the things
that um
that i really loved about this too
because there is a lot of talk of of
megan
um in this docu-series um
it feels like to me that because their
foundation
is so strong and she also was strong
enough to step out and talk about her
struggles
and you know the work that she's put in
with her mental health that it almost
made it a safe
way for harry to do the same did you get
that
impression i i absolutely did i mean we
were in conversations with prince harry
um you know before they went to south
africa the first time
um you know when uh megan
revealed her um you know kind of uh
struggles with depression with anxiety
we didn't know the extent of it at that
time there was just a hint of it
but i do get the sense that they really
support each other um
and they encourage each other and she
has been his number one
supporter and fan and person encouraging
him
to be open and honest and bring his full
self
um to the world and um you know i'm
married a long time
like i think that's that's what couples
do when they really care for each other
um and uh you know
he adores his wife he adores his his
child
um we got to see little glimpses of
archie along the way
um but i do think they they have
supported each other
in this journey um and you know they've
done it at
quite a a personal cost but they
continue to express that it's worth it
that they really really want to help
people
and they're hoping that people seeing
them being so honest will be
we'll encourage people to just talk
about what's happening you know the
first step is just acknowledging
that there's something happening i will
speak for the masses here because we
all love to get a glimpse archie are we
gonna get to see any more he's so cute
are we gonna get to see any more he is
so cute um
he is not in our series there's a
there's a little there's a little bit of
a taste
so um we'll you'll see a little bit
of of archie um and he is just as
adorable
as you would imagine what about megan
will she make a full appearance
or are we just getting kind of you know
because harry is kind of the central
figure here are we just getting kind of
bits and pieces
yeah it's really it's really harry's
story and we're focused on that
um so but i i expect more to come from
them
on this series this is something really
important to both of them
um and they have expressed that so um
i'm really excited to see what where
they go with this next
you know we all speculated that um
harry was so very protective of megan
because he saw what his mother went
through
do you feel like that was the hardest
topic for him because i
i was also very surprised very pleased
but very surprised that he
went so deep there um you know even
talking about
how he could hear the horse's hooves on
on the
the in the pavement that day
you know i think one of the things that
we've all learned and we had
um a really robust team of advisors
working with us on this series people
who are experts in mental health all
around the world
one of the things that we've learned is
that there are auditory
experiences or you know smells or senses
or you know sounds that can trigger
um ptsd and that's exactly what harry
experienced and so you know we really
encouraged him to break that down
so that you know if you've experienced a
traumatic
event you can all of a sudden understand
why
you can't stand to smell roses yeah why
something that
is harmless for other people causes you
such a physical emotional response and
so we really felt like that was
important for harry to share
and you know i'm really personally
grateful to him for breaking
down that way and for having us see you
know
um oprah started crying when she when
he was telling the story of his mother
um and
and you know i think i don't know how
many of us thought about what it would
feel like to be
a little boy walking for a long distance
you know in shock following your
mother's casket
and how that would that would feel for
him and and i think
um you know he understood that was kind
of his
his role at the time and i don't think
anyone had any
harmful intent but understanding
that you know that that did cause him
some real psychological
um issues i think that that's important
to bring out now that we know
let's not repeat that you know one thing
if you don't know but now that we know
and we know that that can happen let's
let's help somebody else so that that's
not their experience
and speaking of it's like in today's
edition of the royals they're just like
us
you know he talked about how his father
um
would tell william and and himself that
these are the these are the things that
are done these are the this is how my
life was this is how
your life will be and he you know talks
about that feeling of no no no we don't
continue the cycle we break the cycle
which how do you how do you even in that
bubble have that awareness to say no
like this is a cycle i need to break
that that's mind-blowing to me
i think that that was is definitely part
of his intense work to understand
um his life and i think that that is
something that megan brought to the
marriage the perspective
of an outsider i think like everyone
prince harry loves his family he um
you know has his relationship with his
family
but sometimes our families you know
inadvertently
can do things that can be difficult to
to handle
so it's not to say there's not love and
admiration and respect for his family
it's to say i had this experience i
don't want that for my children
um and and i think a lot of people
have that we love i love my parents
there are things that i want to do
differently
from the things that my parents did um
and i can hold those two things together
i can both say that's not
you know decades a generation later
we're going to do things differently we
know more
we've had more experiences and i think
that that's what he's experiencing what
he's
he's sharing
you